hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and we're finally
back after the biggest cliffhanger in
the history of black clover and after an
excruciating 3 month wait the new
chapter of black clover is finally here
we got a 15 month time skip we see osta
coming face to face with lucius zogradus
and the black clover end game is now in
full swing i am so excited for this epic
return so let's get into it you guys
know what to do if you enjoy our black
clover content and you want to see more
black lover videos in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it really helps
with that youtube algorithm and of
course if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it might not seem like a
big thing but it actually helps a lot
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
so in case you need a quick reminder
before the break and the time skip it
was revealed that wizard king julius
novacrono was actually the fourth so
gratis sibling his real name is lucius
sokratis and on top of that the wizard
king's time magic comes from the time
magic devil asteroth who as we found out
used to be one of the main cliff off
devils before he mysteriously
disappeared from the underworld and was
replaced
by megicula we also saw adaramelek
bringing lucifero's heart to lucius as
lucius proclaimed that the time has come
well to be fair the time hadn't come yet
at that point because the latest chapter
starts off with a 15 month time skip
well first we see lucius inside the
seventh layer of the underworld he uses
time magic to incapacitate what's left
of lucifero lucifero is saying the kind
of stuff that we've come to expect from
him he's talking about how he's the king
of the devils and how he has the most
powerful magic blah blah blah but lucius
replies that in this world the ones who
are superior at using magic are us
humans he then proceeds to take
lucifero's heart and there is an
implication that he might have eaten it
we don't see him actually eat the heart
but the unofficial translation includes
the word munch after lucius grabs the
heart as if to imply that he was about
to munch on it we'll have to wait for
the official viz.com translation to see
whether munch was really the right word
here but definitely creepy nonetheless
after this scene of lucius owning
lucifero it is revealed that one year
and three months have passed since the
battle in the spain kingdom this means
that all of the characters are now 15
months older meaning that asta yuno noel
and many others are now adults they are
now over 18 years old which is crazy
when you think about it because when the
series started they were only like 15.
we see asta entering a ceremony where he
is about to be honored for his
extraordinary merit as a magic knight
yami and the other squad captains are
there in attendance along with sister
lily father orsi and asta's fellow
orphans from hage village a bunch of
asta's fellow black bulls are also there
and mimosa is there as well it was
honestly heartwarming to see father orsi
actually crying as asta entered the room
and it's clear that asta's entire family
from hagee are super proud of him asta
is then formally named senior magic
knight first class and we learned from
fugolian that this award ceremony had
been delayed by the mysterious
disappearance of damnatio kira this had
also delayed asta's trial but he has
finally been acquitted and he is now
free to receive this honor although
there are still people inside the clover
kingdom who distrust anyone who uses the
power of a devil asta has most certainly
earned this recognition asta is of
course very honored and humbled to be
acknowledged by the squad captains and
he is now only a few steps away from
achieving his ultimate dream of becoming
the wizard king however as is tradition
at this point it turns out that asta is
once again lagging behind his rival yuno
during the time skip yuno was already
named a grand magic knight which is one
step above asta in the rankings and in
fact real comments that yuno just broke
his record as the youngest mage to ever
become a grand magic knight fugoleon
then makes it clear that asta deserves
the same title as you know but it seems
that the stigma surrounding asta's devil
and the whole trial process is what has
been dragging asta down during these
past 15 months basically he would have
been promoted together with yuno but he
couldn't because he had to beat the
charges first at the banquet following
the ceremony a few people inquire about
the whereabouts of the wizard king
himself who clearly should have been
present at the ceremony but these
questions are brushed off because julius
does have a tendency to transform and
just sneak around incognito we then
learned that fugolian nosel and
merauleona are all candidates for
becoming the next wizard king but it
looks like they all declined the offer
marijuana doesn't want the title she
doesn't want to deal with that type of
stuff and nozell and fugolian seem to
believe that they must become much
stronger before taking on such an
important position even though the spate
and heart kingdoms have mostly recovered
from the recent conflict and the
continent appears to be at peace there
is still demonic activity out there on
the fringes of the clover kingdom so
they're not out of the woods yet in fact
juno and the golden dawn along with the
black bulls who are not present at the
ceremony have been sent out to
investigate this demonic activity and
they are traveling inside the black bull
mecca we then learned something that i
personally wasn't a big fan of and this
is an issue that i talked about in
previous videos as well it turns out
that even now 15 months after charlotte
confessed her feelings to yami there has
still been absolutely no progress
in their relationship yami wasn't even
aware that she said she loves him
because he was passed out and i guess no
one thought to tell him anything
charlotte included and so charlotte just
went back to being super shy and awkward
around him although it's even worse now
because even the normally clueless yami
finally realizes that she's acting
pretty weird and that is when finral
finally decides to tell yami that
charlotte loves him and that she
confessed to him back in the spade
kingdom and yeah i guess no one thought
to say anything about this to yami for
15 freaking months until finral just
casually dropped it now yami then
decides to take a potty break so that he
can sit down on the toilet and process
this information i guess we now know why
we see yami on the toilet so often the
man clearly likes to contemplate the big
questions in life while sitting on the
john
i love yami as a character but he is
just so naive and oblivious when it
comes to romance that it's crazy to
think that he's supposed to be a 30 year
old adult man he's acting all surprised
that charlotte loves him because he
thought that she hated him and it's like
man have you ever seen atsundere before
like come on yami get it together
meanwhile it seems that asta has been
dealing with similar stuff from noel and
mimosa who have apparently spent the
last 15 months feeling shy and
self-conscious around him but neither of
them has said anything to him either so
their relationships have progressed
about as much as yami's and charlotte's
yay that is super exciting and
definitely not extremely frustrating at
all then as everyone prepares to leave
the ceremony asta decides that he is
going to propose to sister lily one more
time and now that he's an adult this
will be a genuine and serious proposal
he asks sister lily to marry him he
tells her that he is serious and that
this will be the last time that he
proposes to her noel and mimosa are both
super shook as they await sister lily's
answer but they don't have any real
reason to worry sister lily thanks asta
but she tells him that she sees him as a
little brother she considers him to be
her family so she cannot marry him i
mean she is also a nun although to be
fair i am not sure whether the nuns in
the black clover world have to remain
celibate asta bravely says that he
understands and even though he always
wanted to marry her he understands that
sometimes you can't change how people
feel and even though he was just
rejected by lily he renews his vow to
achieve his other goal that of becoming
the wizard king lily is proud of asta
and she tells him that he can do it but
that is when another guest suddenly
shows up to the party that guest is none
other than lucius sokratis who appears
and congratulates asta for making it
this far but then as a confused asta
looks upon him lucius states that this
is the end the lighthearted awards
ceremony that was all about honoring
asta's achievements and exploring cute
romantic relationships takes a sudden
dark turn as asta comes face to face
with the true final villain of the
series the dark wizard king something
that caught my eye very quickly is the
fact that the star on lucius's forehead
is slightly different than it was at the
end of the previous chapter three of the
lines on the right side of the mark have
disappeared while the other five are
still there i wonder what that means is
the changing mark an indicator that
lucius cannot stay in control of
julius's body forever and maybe when
that mark disappears completely he will
also disappear and julius will get his
body back
maybe but if only three lines
disappeared in 15 months and there are
still five lines left then lucius still
has plenty of time to do whatever he has
been planning and of course this is just
speculation anyway those lines may have
disappeared due to a completely
different reason that is only going to
be revealed later now my question is
this
why did lucius wait 15 months before
making contact with asta what has lucius
been up to all this time when he emerged
at the end of the previous chapter i
assumed that he would now be launching
his master plan but it seems that
another 15 months passed without anyone
even realizing that something was wrong
with the wizard king how is that even
possible and why did lucius decide to
wait so long wouldn't someone have
noticed that something was so terribly
wrong with one of the most important
people in the clover kingdom in a period
of over a year
definitely let me know what you guys
think down in the comments because i am
very curious to find out what exactly
lucius is planning to do now also i
really want to know what the true nature
of the relationship between lucius and
julius is there seem to be a lot of
people out there who believe that julius
novacrono never existed and that he was
just a fake persona created by lucius to
trick everyone but that doesn't quite
add up to me julius has done some
genuinely good and selfless things
multiple times in the past and he even
risked his own life to save the capital
from poetry chibi julius also seemed to
be genuinely shocked when he realized
that he was the time devil's host and he
even tried to warn damnatio before
lucius took over on top of that we know
that the fourth zograda sibling used to
be in a wheelchair so to me this points
to the fact that there probably is a
real julius but his body has been
usurped by lucius we don't know how or
when this happened but i am excited to
discover this man's full backstory what
do you guys think is julius just a
made-up character or is he a real person
whose body was taken over by lucius and
what about the time devil asteroth where
is he in this whole story definitely
share your thoughts down in the comments
below oh and most importantly of all are
you happy or frustrated with the
progression of the romantic ships in the
story personally i'm pretty frustrated
with how little progress has been made
especially during such a long time skip
but that's just my opinion if you guys
enjoyed this black clover video and you
want us to keep it going leave a quick
like and comment it only takes you a
second but it really helps me out a lot
and if you haven't already consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to directly support
the channel subscribing is totally free
but it means a lot you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime outpour patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the toasted qi corey mcgowan big
buddhist and jeremy pontier and i can't
forget all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor fat boy games
kaido might be a duck alivania and anime
s codem if you guys enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon or
here through youtube memberships even a
single dollar helps and it means a lot
to us as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys